now like with the previous problem I
want to show you another way of solving
this one because maybe you're like I'm a
bit sick of Pythagoras Theorem we've
been doing this a lot okay there is
another way to solve this you might say
it's a bit more direct because I am
still going to put some constructions on
but they're going to be slightly
different because
um I'm not going to put this new sort of
imaginary rectangle around it however
it's going to require a slightly bit
more sophisticated amounts and you'll
see why in a second
have a look here right I don't know if
when you look at this your instinct is
to draw that shape on the outside my
instinct was actually to draw a
different kind of shape in here once I
had my diagonal so if I put that same in
fact I'm just going to copy it
I'm going to put that same diagonal
there let's just grab that
since I've already drawn it
oh I grabbed the triangle that's not
what I wanted
let's try
I'm still grabbing the triangle I'm just
going to delete it because then I can
get the real thing that I want there we
go
okay so let's put this back in place
like so
okay now how else can I find what this
length is well you might be able to have
noticed that this length here can
actually sit in multiple different
shapes not just the square in which we
found it not just the rectangle that we
created before but if I just join up
this length here see how I've got that
corner there in the middle and join it
to that corner there of the square
what I've got here is uh noting that
this diagonal here is the thing that
we're after
it's diagonal that was much thicker than
I intended this diagonal here is what
I'm after but it is the longest side in
you can see there's this um this
triangle here which is um it's kind of
got this obtuse angle in here right now
the reason why this length is something
which jumps out at me is because that
three and that four are two of
two-thirds of a Pythagorean Triad right
this is a five centimeter length here so
being that this is a five
and this is a CX I've got the these two
known angles and then all I need to do
is relate them using what piece of
information will get me from two sides
and this angle in between to the third
side enter this is the cosine rule right
now obviously the cosine rule is
slightly more involved than Pythagoras's
Theorem and that's why this is probably
less of an elegant approach like this
required
um really really simple math like you
could convince someone who'd not heard
any trigonometry that this is true
but I can still do this provided that I
can work out um what's going on with
this angle here in this corner right
because the cosine rule requires the
magnitude of not just this angle but
actually the angle all the way across in
this 5 6 D triangle okay now I've got a
rain angle there that's good but how do
I work out what's going on with this
Theta well what I'm going to do is use
the fact that this Theta sits in a right
angle triangle it's the three four five
triangle that I noticed before right so
what I'm going to note down is that in
this triangle I can say cos Theta is
adjacent on hypotenuse which in this
case let's see where the Theta is
adjacent is three hypotenuse is five so
that's three over five
now I also am going to need later on and
you'll see why in a second the sine of
this angle so I might as well just note
it down while I'm doing the cosine it's
going to be 4 over 5 and pay attention
in a moment for where this is going to
be useful
so if I wanted to work out what this
length was then I'm going to have to use
the cosine rule to find this D squared
equals 6 squared plus 5 squared minus 2
times 5 times 6 uh cause of this right
this bigger angle okay I should probably
just say that um right out the gate I
should say that D Squared is going to be
well in fact you know what let's
actually just write the normal cosine
rule so it's c squared equals the radio
I remember it is it's Pythagoras Theorem
a squared plus b squared minus 2 a b cos
C this is the kind of compensation
factor for the fact that I don't have a
right angled triangle this part is
Pythagoras which works when uh C is 90
degrees because COS of 90 degrees just
gives you zero and that leaves you just
with regular Pythagoras Theorem but when
C is not 90 degrees you have to
compensate either you have a longer
hypotenuse or a shorter one depending on
what the included angle is equal to okay
so you can see I need COS of this angle
here which is that angle there
is going to be
theta plus 90 degrees so to work out
cause of that you can see that's
actually the next piece of the puzzle
that's why I need cos and sound so let's
work out what that is I'll keep it in
Orange actually since it's what I um
started writing I need COS of theta plus
90 degrees and it's related to COS of
theta and sine of theta
now what I'm going to do is uh yeah I'll
carry on this working in Orange right
there's two ways to go about this okay
the first way is if you are good with
your identities for
um uh what we call this I guess these
are kind of compound angles right it's
there's a Theta but there's also a 90
degree in here right uh you could use
your knowledge of graphing which I'll
show you in a second just to immediately
know what this is going to be equal to
in terms of these two ratios or
alternatively and you can see it's not
just trigonometry that you need you also
need to know some trigonometric
expansions you might remember that COS
of a plus b
is it's a cause cause sign sign
expansion right so it's cause of the
first angle cause of the second angle
take away sine of the first angle sine
of the second angle so again if you are
someone who is uh from an earlier year
and you're like I haven't met any of
this right uh in Australia where I teach
you don't meet this stuff until year 11.
maybe you're looking at this and
thinking yeah you know what Pythagoras
Theorem not looking so bad now but I'm
still going to see where this leads and
it's a nice confirmation of what the
answer is from a very different approach
okay
now I'm going to continue running on
with this I know what COS of 90 and sine
of 90 are equal to COS of 90 I actually
stated it just now is zero and sine of
90 is actually just one so all I end up
with is minus sine Theta which I
actually just got from this right angle
triangle up above so it's negative 4 on
5. now you might have known and I sort
of alluded to this earlier
you might have known that COS of theta
plus 90 degrees would be equal to
negative sine Theta without going
through this expansion in another way
let me show you right
I'm going to need let's put a little bit
of extra space here
because I'm not up to my last question
here all right here we go
so you might have thought okay what is
um I'll make this a bit bigger what is
COS of 90 degrees what does it actually
look like well if I were to draw let's
move that up a little bit I didn't
position that very well did I if we were
to draw a very very rough cos curve
right so here is a set of axes
let's go with orange so here is what the
cause curve looks like that's pretty
horrendous but it'll do for now it only
needs to be rough what is that 90
degrees that Plus 90 degrees what does
it do to the graph and the answer is it
shifts it horizontally 90 degrees which
direction answer it's in the opposite
direction to this this is a plus which
sounds like it's going to the right but
actually it's going it's it's a reverse
relationship there so I'm going to take
this graph and I'm just going to draw
that same thing but 90 degrees to the uh
to the left okay so what I'm going to do
is
let's draw it in a color like this if
you imagine picking a few critical spots
like here here here and here and moving
them to the left 90 degrees because
remembering this is 90 this is 180 here
in the middle like so it's not very
accurate I know this is 270 and this
would be at 360 right so what I'll do is
I move all of them over so they end up
here
here and here I hope you can see the
movement I might just draw it this way
this one's moved that way
this one's moved that way this one's
moved that way and wow that's horrendous
let's fix that up this one's moved
across
two there
all right what graph do we actually get
well you can see if I go from left to
right I'm going to get this kind of
shape wow that's so bad I've got to do
it again this kind of shape here and
then because I've got a little bit left
over you can see this needs to sort of
complete down like so all right so what
I've just drawn here in blue is COS of
theta plus 90 degrees because the orange
graph was just regular old COS of theta
now have a look at it have a look at
this graph that I've drawn here can you
see if I get rid of the COS graph right
can you see that this is the same as a
sine graph but upside down so that is
why COS of theta plus 90 degrees is the
same as negative sine Theta it's here's
the sine Theta graph and I've just
flipped it upside down so that was
another way that you could reason
because of theta plus 90 degrees equals
negative sign without having to go
through the expansions but you still
needed to know this fact up here
okay so now that I've got COS of theta
plus 90 that's that's that angle right
in there let's do it in Orange because
that's where we've been doing it right
so now that I know what cause of that
angle is I can use cosine rule right so
I can say D Squared because that is the
let's just go back that is this longest
side of the triangle here is going to be
equal to 5 squared plus 6 squared
there's the Pythagoras part of the
cosine rule and here comes the
compensating Factor so it's double
the product of the two sides and then
COS of theta plus 90 degrees which we
just went and evaluated in an orange up
here so I'm just going to do a straight
substitution in a second
all right let's go ahead and tidy this
up so you can see this is 25 plus 36
take away 2 times 5 times 6 is just 60
the COS thing actually let's just put it
in Orange to keep it going that's
negative for over five so you can see
that I'm going to get
let's have a look here so 25 plus 36
that's 61 and then here the negatives
are going to cancel with each other give
me a positive 60 divided by 5 is
12 and so 12 times 4 is 48 so I'm going
to get
plus 48 here so what am I finding D
squared equals oh surprise surprise
109 like I evaluated when I was just
doing it with the regular or Pythagoras
once I saw it in that rectangle that I
constructed so again like I did earlier
I'm going to pause there because I think
you know what to do with the rest of it
but it is really reassuring even using
quote unquote more sophisticated maths
you still end up with the same solution